Hello everyone. My name is Ann and I am a practitioner here at Conner's Clinic and I am also one of the people.
We have a few people that do go through the genetic reports in our trained and certified to analyze and interpret the data.
So today in this video what we are going to go through is what you will be receiving when we have your genetic report.
So does take about 8 to 10 weeks to get that information back from the lab.
Once we do get it back, we receive about 230 page report. That's the full report.
So you will have access to that, but that is the information that we use to, you know,
obviously analyze all of that information and then what we do is we put together a genetic summary.
So what you have on the screen here is the genetic summary, which is going to look like this and this correlates exactly with the full report.
So it's kind of a snapshot of each of the sections of the full report in a description of the important genes we may not touch on every single gene in the report.
But we do hit on the important ones in each section. So we have a description now, obviously in the full report, there is a description of each gene.
There's general information just kind of talking about the function of the gene and, you know, what it means to have a variant.
So some of it might look very similar as to what is in the report, but we try to make it a little more, you know, digestible, I guess you would say as I'm looking at the gut health genes.
So we try to just break down the information. So it's a little more understandable because this is a new topic for most people.
And so a lot of new words, a lot of new terms. So it can be very overwhelming.
So the summary is really supposed to break it down into, you know, easily understandable components and then also to touch on the most important things for you based on your genetic variants.
So you can see here at the top, it would have your name and then we have an highlighted in yellow here. Pay attention to the yellow highlighted genes.
These are at an increased risk for you. The rest of the gene specific information is included for your reference.
So it's exactly that we will have the things that are important for you as an individual highlighted in yellow.
That means you have more variants than average.
So your genes in that category are more at risk, or maybe it's just a specific gene that is the most important in that family, that category and you have variants on that specific gene.
And so we've highlighted it because just that one genetic variant, you know, bears more weight.
And so we need to make sure we're addressing this. So this is what it will look like.
So, and this is, you know, about 10 or 12 pages. So again, it highlights in yellow, the things that are important for you.
And so the rest of the information certainly can help you understand that, you know, all of the genes and maybe, oh, these are interesting.
These are relating to gluten. I don't have variants here, but it's interesting that this specific gene is related to that.
So for your information, and then we also may have some suggestions.
So if something is highlighted in yellow, we may have some suggestions for you to possibly begin to implement to help support the genetic variant.
So it might be a supplement and might be something that has to do with a lifestyle intervention.
It might be a dietary related component, or it might be something like this.
As we can see here, these are the genes that are related to peanut allergy or mold sensitivity.
So we have information on where you could do some mold testing, you know, to see if you're exposed to mold.
And if you have these genetic variants, that means you don't get rid of mold, detox mold as well as you should.
So it could be a component in some of the health symptoms or conditions that you might be dealing with.
So important to know if you are being exposed to mold in the home so you can remedy that.
So take a look at all of these things that are highlighted in yellow.
You can see here some of these are supplement suggestions.
Supplements can be viewed on our web store.
You can research the supplement.
Dr. Conner's is very good about getting information on our web store.
Usually there is a video relating to that particular supplement.
What it's good for, what it's doing, you know, looking at the ingredients.
So you can just look at that research that you can decide if you'd like to purchase the recommended supplement or not.
So take a look at that and, you know, here in this example, we have and said listed.
So there is a gene that is related to insect sensitivity.
And if you have variants there, it's important to be careful when you're choosing some of those over the counter.
Pain, pain medications, for example, Advil, if you have variants, you don't metabolize the Advil as well.
Could be more toxic to the liver.
So you need to be careful.
Something really good to know.
So great information can be revealed on this genetic report.
And then, you know, you can make some alternatives.
So these are just a list of alternatives for pain, things like that.
So again, pay attention to the yellow highlights.
And then also, you know, there might be a number of different supplements listed.
And so that doesn't mean you have to take all of those supplements.
It's just options.
So it's, you know, we have things listed that are kind of all possible interventions for a specific gene that might be highlighted.
So it doesn't mean you have to take them all.
Really that action steps, if we look over here on the right side of the screen,
the action steps are what we are asking you to do specifically based on our interpretation.
So this is where we would get into specifics where, you know,
we might have three or four supplements that might be beneficial.
But we want you to take one specific one,
because obviously we're looking at that specific gene for a variant,
but we're also keeping in mind all of your genetics as a whole,
because they do interact with each other.
So we want to be careful when we're, you know, we don't want to micromanage one specific gene
or only look in one area and treat that because there are domino kind of effects,
downward effects that may happen if you start manipulating one gene, you know,
it's part of a whole system.
So it can affect, you know, the whole system or other systems that it is related to.
So when we do make our recommendations,
we are keeping individual genes in mind,
we're keeping entire pathways in mind to help support you.
So these guidelines listed out on your action steps will be the specifics
that we would like you to begin to implement based on our analysis,
based on your genetic weaknesses, and it's kind of a starting point.
So, you know, with genetics and with all, you know, kind of interventions,
you know, it's a work in progress.
So we have starting points and we may implement a few things,
and then we can check back if we, okay, how are you doing after a month, you know,
taking these new supplements, you know, there can be follow-ups involved,
follow-up appointments.
If you want to recheck or talk about things, there is a fee for that.
So certainly you can call and get on the schedule,
but there is a fee associated with those follow-up visits,
if you would like them.
But the action steps will list out dietary interventions, you know,
and if you're a current patient of ours,
we have already made some dietary and supplement recommendations.
So anything on the action steps would be in addition
to what we've already recommended.
If you're a genetic only, you know, patient,
and you're just utilizing the services for genetics,
then, you know, we wouldn't necessarily have any additional or, excuse me,
new or, excuse me, previous recommendations.
So these would be your recommendations.
So diet and then we will have lifestyle recommendations.
So again, you know, reiterating and said sensitivity
to use alternatives for pain management,
mold sensitive, consider mold testing.
So a number of different lifestyle interventions
that can help support genetic pathways.
And then the final area would be supplements to add.
With those specific supplements that we'd like you to begin implementing.
So you'll get all of this information
after we've completed our analysis.
And you'll also be getting a video that walks you through a full genetic report
and kind of the explanation of individual genes and the function.
So you can take a look at that, watch that, compare it to what you have.
And then, you know, kind of go from there.
And so hopefully this helps give you some information on what to expect.
So again, the highlighted yellow genes are the ones
that would be important for you to pay attention to based on your variance.
And then the action steps are giving you the specifics
that we want you to begin implementing.
All right, I hope that helps.
And I hope that you get a lot out of your genetic report.
And all of this good genetic information,
you might need to revisit it a few time.
Again, it's a lot of new information, new terms,
and so it might take a while for it to sink in.
And you might need to revisit this information multiple times
to really kind of understand and get a good grasp, totally normal.
All right, well, I hope you have a good day.
Bye-bye.